Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Daniel Lubetzky, the founder
of the groundbreaking
snack company KIND
returns to the Tank.
Your product
has to be your hero,
and it has to stand
on its own merits.
Let's talk about
how the sausage gets made.
It's time to make shopping with
babies fun, safe, and simple.
‐Together, we can...
‐Change chilling forever.
On the Tandem Boogie,
every wave is a party wave.
‐Whoo! Whoo!
‐Waves right behind you.
‐Are you out of your ‐‐
‐We're not out of our minds.
‐Your presentation sucked.
‐We're onto something.
You didn't come into
the Dolphin Tank.
I so want to
rip you to pieces.
I'm dying to rip you
to pieces.
What?!
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a way for carnivores
to eat a little healthier.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Phil Wong.
And I'm from Brooklyn, New York.
Let's talk about how
the sausage gets made.
So many Americans
want to eat less meat,
whether it's for their health,
for our planet,
or for animal welfare.
But it's no secret that most
aren't ready to go vegetarian.
So why are we stuck
with an all‐or‐nothing choice
when we go
to the grocery store?
We thought, why can't we
put veggies and meat
into a product
that people would love?
Well, Sharks,
that's where we come in.
We're meeting in the middle.
Introducing Misfit Foods,
a line of delicious sausages
that are half chicken
and half veggies and spices.
Our three flavors
will knock your socks off.
And they're made
with sustainability in mind,
helping people eat less meat
by putting more delicious food
on the dinner table,
because we believe
that change can taste good,
one link at a time.
So, Sharks, don't miss out
on this one.
250K for 5% of our company.
Wow.
Sharks, in front of you,
we have our sausages
prepared three different ways.
The first is my favorite.
It's our Sweet Potato Andouille
mac and cheese.
Next,
our Kale Chimichurri tacos.
And last is a classic
squash Italian
on a bun with the fixings.
Greiner: Wow.
The Citrus Kale is delicious.
Thank you.
I'm so glad to hear it, Lori.
Really good.
One thing that I noticed
that I really like
is that your sodium
is lower
than the typical
chicken sausages that I buy.
And the other thing, too,
is that we have about
40% less cholesterol
than your typical
chicken sausage, as well.
And that's something that
our consumers really care about.
Phil, who's the market
you're going after?
Like, are you trying to get
people that are meat eaters
to eat less meat?
Absolutely,
and, you know,
I think the proof
is kind of in the pudding.
We're in our first full year
in market right now,
and we're on track
for $1.2 million in sales.
‐Wow.
And so, you know,
a good portion of those people
are just, you know,
your pure carnivores.
What's your actual sales
to date?
So we've done
just under 800K to date.
How are you selling it,
direct or through retail?
We're about 20%
brick and mortar,
and that's Whole Foods,
and 80% online.
How did you come up with this?
What's your background?
So, you know, food's always been
a really huge part of my life.
I grew up in a family
of immigrants.
So my mom is from Indonesia.
My dad is from Macao.
And so my connection
to Indonesia and Macao
when I was growing up
was through food.
And when I got to college
at Georgetown,
I started learning more
about just, like,
how huge our environmental
footprint is with our food.
So I started wondering,
was there a way to use delicious
food to help the environment?
And so I started Misfit in
the kitchen that I was sharing
with the six other guys
I was living with at the time.
Really?
Yeah, they weren't
too happy about it.
Did you raise money
to do this?
Yeah. So we've raised
$2 million to date.
‐Hello.
‐Wow.
‐What?
We're here to not hit
a single or a double, right?
We're here to hit a home run.
So what was your last valuation
of the company at?
So the last valuation
was $4 million.
Well, we haven't
even talked about
what it sells for
and what it costs yet.
So typically, we're selling
for $4.13 a unit
to the grocery store.
Our cost is about
$2.91 a unit.
Okay, so that's
your biggest challenge.
‐And what do they sell it for?
‐What do they retail it at?
And so they're retailing it
for anywhere from $5.99
to $7.99 a unit.
Now, our gross margins work out
to about 29%.
What's really important
to know about that
is that we hit break even
in May of this year,
and I think that points
to the fact
that we don't have to
market this product a ton
and, you know, spend a bunch on
slotting fees, promotional fees
to get people
to buy this product.
Are you spending money
on marketing today?
Very little. It's less
than 5% of our first revenue.
Good for you.
The refrigerated
and frozen categories
have eluded me
in making a lot of money.
I've made investments
in it.
It's burned up
a lot of my hours,
which is valuable to me,
and I haven't really had
a huge hit with it yet.
I'm out.
I'm a vegetarian,
and I think it's innovative,
but I don't know
if I believe in the trend.
I think consumers
want to go
one way or another.
You might be right,
but I don't share that vision.
I'm out.
Thank you, Robert.
So your valuation
seems a little bit rich.
Mr. Wonderful, could you, like,
soften him up for me?
‐Soften him up?
‐Well, I would gladly do that.
O'Leary: I mean, you've
obviously done multiple rounds
at valuations
lower than this.
And then you come
in the Shark Tank
to get a premium investor
and charge them a premium,
which is not correct,
because a Shark brings value
that an ordinary investor can't.
Could you add
"Shame on you"?
If you want to get
an investor,
you're gonna have to
take a haircut.
That's what's gonna happen.
I'm gonna give you...
$250,000 for 15%.
And I'm thinking
that's generous.
Well, there's
your first haircut.
Man, I shaved my head
like two weeks ago.
I can't afford
to lose any more of this.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: I think good product
speaks for itself, right?
It's gonna sell.
I do wonder if people will start
knocking you off like crazy.
I think it's so smart
that I think you kind of
have to race to the market.
Lubetzky:
Mm‐hmm. Mm‐hmm.
So I'm gonna
give you an offer.
It's gonna be
a little bit sharkier.
I'm gonna go $250,000,
but I'm gonna ask
for 18%.
Lori,
thank you for that offer.
Thank you, Lori.
Okay, so let's
talk about this, Phil.
Phil, let me ask
a couple questions.
Yeah.
Do you think
you have too many SKUs?
Because that's
a challenge ‐‐
you know, trying to get
just that much shelf space.
Like, for me,
if I was a flexitarian,
these would have ‐‐
this would be too much, right?
I'm not a curry guy
and I'm not ‐‐
Citrus Kale,
maybe I'll try it.
But, you know,
if it was simpler ‐‐
I just want a sausage,
you know,
where I could put it on a bun
and eat it at a cookout
and know it's healthier
and lower‐calorie.
Lubetzky:
Mark, you're so right.
This is incredibly important
for people to understand.
Every time my team
and I innovate
and we come up with all these
esoteric ideas, they're fun,
but they will never beat
the working horse.
And many entrepreneurs are
trying so hard to differentiate
and they don't build
that working horse.
Are you willing to do
just a workhorse product?
I had no idea you were
a chef, Mark ‐‐ no idea.
I'm not a chef, but I know
how to dominate markets.
Are you gonna
make an offer?
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Phil has offers on the table
from Daniel and Lori
for his half‐chicken,
half‐veggie sausage company,
Misfit Foods,
but Mark may also be interested.
Are you gonna make an offer?
Cuban: Yes.
So do you want to try
to do something together?
Okay, so...
How about $250,000 for 15%,
two Sharks.
Two of us.
Never has
happened before.
Wow.
This is the first time
we're getting married.
You're getting a haircut
no matter what happens.
So, Phil,
that takes your valuation
from $5 million
you walked in with
down to $1.6 million,
but you get two Sharks
and a chef to tell you
what to put in the sausage
that doesn't eat meat.
And he'll rewrite
your whole business plan.
There you go.
You get a guy that doesn't
eat your product
to tell you what to do.
And a mentor who's done it
every step of the way
and who's gonna guide you.
You would be a fool not to walk
out with one of these offers.
Which Shark or Sharks
do you want to go with?
Wong: Gosh.
I mean, I would be honored
to officiate this wedding.
The valuation is a little rich.
I'm wondering if we could bring
you two in at 300K for 15%.
300K for 15%?
O'Leary:
That's not crazy.
I would do that.
You've got a deal.
Done.
‐Congratulations.
‐Whoo!
I would hug you, but
we'd have to quarantine
for two more weeks.
Greiner: Good job.
Phil, we're really excited
to work with you.
We are very excited about you.
We are going to crush it.
Wong: Thank you.
Crush it.
I'm so excited.
If we don't create
a whole new category
and dominate that category,
I'll be really disappointed.
We'll make it happen.
Thank you, guys.
‐Phil, congratulations.
‐Yeah, congrats.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Oh.
Wow, that was not what
I was expecting to happen.
So we came out
with both Daniel and Mark.
I mean, both of those are like
two huge business idols for me.
And so I'm kind of fanboy‐ing
right now.
It's gonna be a game changer for
our business, that's for sure.
Narrator: Earlier this season,
Angie Kupper and Matt Mundt
made a deal with Mark Cuban
and Lori Greiner
for Hug Sleep,
a swaddle for adults.
You got yourself a deal.
Let's see what
they're up to now.
Since "Shark Tank," our lives
have flipped upside down.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had been in business
for about 16 months.
We sold $490,000
in total sales,
which is about
5,500 Sleep Pods.
The night we aired,
something magical happened.
We sold over $2 million
in sales,
well over
25,000 Sleep Pods.
Kupper:
Our focus quickly shifted to,
"How are we going to be able
to fill all these orders?"
Before airing
on "Shark Tank,"
our manufacturer
was able to make
about 200 to 300 units
per week.
We were able
to scale production
to well over
10,000 units a week.
In just three
short months,
We've done over
$4.1 million in sales
and have sold
over 44,000 Sleep Pods.
Sleep is everything
to everybody.
If you can't sleep,
then everything else craters.
Especially during
these stressful times.
Greiner: The future
for this business is bright.
Right now,
they can direct to consumer,
but in the future,
they can also fulfill to stores
nationwide and globally.
They've developed new products,
and they've even developed one
for kids.
Hug Sleep will help men, women,
and children all sleep better.
There's no reason why you can't
be a $100 million company.
Between you guys
and Lori and I,
I have no doubt
we'll get there.
I only have two words.
Let's go!
[ Laughs ]
Kupper:
There's a huge connection
between our physical health
and our mental health.
There are so many people
out there dealing with PTSD,
anxiety, insomnia,
and sensory issues every day,
and being able to get
a better night's sleep
is one of the best things
that we can do
to take care of ourselves.
The last year has been
an incredibly stressful
time for everyone,
so it's been really
rewarding to us
that Sleep Pod has been able
to help thousands of people
at least get
a better night's sleep.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a product
designed to keep your cool.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks, I'm Chase.
Our company is Chill Systems,
and this is the Chiller.
It's a portable beverage cooler
with freezing gel built in.
[ Footsteps approach ]
And...
Hey, Sharks.
This is Brian.
Sorry I'm late.
I had to buy ice.
Oof. The Chiller
doesn't need ice.
Man! I had to stop
at the inconvenience store.
Now I got to
break this up.
I put ‐‐
[ Grunting ]
♪♪
[ Sighs ]
I put the Chiller
in my freezer last night,
loaded my favorite drinks
before I left,
and now they're ice‐cold.
These drinks will be cold
in...mnh‐mnh‐mnh, a while.
This chills many types
of cans and bottles,
even big bottles
like champagne.
This cooler
can hold all that.
Well, sure.
Look at the size of it.
Yeah.
It's super heavy, too.
The Chiller is the future
of portable beverage cooling.
Enjoy hours of ice‐cold drinks
anywhere.
Save time, money,
and the environment.
Oh, boy.
Yeah, that's bad.
[ Laughter ]
Good thing
we at Chill Systems
are offering
a more sustainable solution.
Choosing a Chiller reduces waste
of clean water
and single‐use plastics.
And we proudly donate a portion
of every purchase
to support clean water projects
around the world.
And you can, too.
Partner with us.
We're seeking $150,000
for 15% equity.
And together, we can...
Both:
Change chilling forever.
Sharks, you each have samples
complete with chilled drinks.
Cuban: Chill.
Greiner: So this doubles.
You can either do cans.
Yep.
Or you take the cans out
like I just did.
‐And then it's for a bottle.
‐That's right.
‐Oh.
‐It's incredibly versatile.
It only holds three cans.
I mean,
I don't know about you,
but I'll get through this
in about 45 minutes.
Sure, and, you know, Kevin,
we've heard that feedback before
from macho men
on the Internet.
"Only three beers?"
The Chiller cools three beers
or a bottle of wine at a time.
But the point is,
if I want to take a case ‐‐
As soon as you have a cold one,
you take a cold one out.
You put another one in
for cooling.
‐How long does this stay cold?
‐Six hours.
‐What were the sales?
We've done $111,000
to date.
That's over
the last two years.
We started with
a Kickstarter campaign.
We did $51,000
on Kickstarter.
Cuban: What's it cost?
Okay, the Chiller you have
in front of you,
our product cost
is awful.
Never, ever start
any type of response ‐‐
I understand.
‐Let me get there.
‐"It's awful."
Let me get there.
That was about $18 a unit
to build.
Now, then we had to import
the units, $3.50 a unit.
So now you're up
to 22 bucks.
We added those sleeves,
added another $11, okay?
Now you're up to $32?
All the way up to $37
for that one that you have
in front of you.
To make it?
‐To make it?
‐The cost?
‐Yes.
‐Wow.
‐$37?
Let me get there.
That was our first run
of inventory, okay?
And since then,
we've been able
to bring that cost
down to $18.
The one you have
in front of you,
we're actually selling those
currently into retail at a loss
at $30
to prove out the market.
This is the first sustainable
portable beverage chiller.
When you say this is
the only sustainable cooler,
I'm not so sure
that that's true.
Herjavec: Yeah, I don't know
if I buy that.
Like, I get I'm saving
the plastic bag.
But look at the amount
of plastic that's in this.
That is built
to last forever.
All the materials
are also recyclable.
No, but so is the plastic,
isn't it?
Only 9% of thrown‐away plastic
is recycled.
Lubetzky: Give me the reason why
you decided to go in this space.
Because you sound like fun guys,
great energy.
Of all the things you could
have done in the world,
why did you choose you wanted
to make the umpteenth cooler?
So, Chase and I have had
good jobs out of school.
He went to work at Google,
and I went to work at Apple.
And two years into that ‐‐
What'd you do
for Google and Apple?
I was in sales.
I was in finance.
And so we were there
for about two years
before we came up
with this idea.
And so for the first
two years of this,
we were building this
on the side
on the nights,
on the weekends.
Are you still working
at your jobs?
We're not.
No, we quit them two years ago.
This is full time for this?
We've been doing this full time
for two years.
And are you making money
to sustain yourselves?
Not yet.
No, not profitable yet.
We have not taken a salary since
we left our jobs two years ago.
Do you want me to make a call
to get your jobs back?
No.
We are very happy doing this.
We believe in the mission.
But you guys had
promising careers.
There is a massive amount
of plastic waste.
You probably got stock options.
You're making great money.
You both have fantastic jobs
in growth companies.
We're passionate
about this project.
And then you know that story of
the Sirens singing on the rocks?
[ Vocalizes ]
‐We felt the need.
‐And it's a cooler.
You look from the boat.
We felt the need for it
ourselves.
It's a cooler
pulling you in
from your fantastic jobs
and stock options.
[ Vocalizes ]
‐The cooler draws you in.
‐That's right.
That's right. We love it.
Then the boat crashes
into the rocks.
And now you're here
with a cooler.
Who is your number‐one
competitor?
‐Ice.
‐Ice? [ Chuckles ]
I want you to know, for this
Season 12 of "Shark Tank,"
I actually went to get
some anger management therapy.
Because I didn't
want to be mean.
I wanted to be
the new Mr. Wonderful.
And I am working very hard right
now to be a nice Mr. Wonderful.
I look at this
and I say to myself, "Okay.
I'm gonna take this
and put this thing in my freezer
for an extended period of time.
I guess I'll take out the roast
and the chicken that's there
and I'll put this in here,
and then I'm gonna take
three cans of beer ‐‐
just three, not more."
‐At a time.
‐At at time.
‐Three at a time.
And I'm going to go somewhere
with this thing.
Right.
$160,000.
Kevin, remember your therapy,
please.
$160,000 for 15%.
‐Oh, my God.
‐$1 million.
Plus more, even.
‐Are you out of your ‐‐
‐We're not out of our minds.
Why?
Would you like to talk
about the valuation?
Why would you do this?
I mean,
this stuff is tchotchke.
They give it away
at beer companies.
There's a million coolers.
Stop, stop. Oh.
It's sustainable.
It's convenient.
I so want to rip you
to pieces.
I'm dying to rip you
What are you gonna do,
Kevin?
You must stop this.
There is no hope.
This is a really bad idea.
Coolers? Why?
I don't even buy
the sustainability thing.
There's all kinds of plastic
in this thing.
I hate it.
I'm out.
Cuban: Guys, look, first of all,
your presentation sucked.
The next time you sell it,
sell it.
Don't make it worse.
Just stick to your features
and what sets you apart
so people truly
understand it quickly.
Sure.
So while I think
you got a shot,
it does everything
as advertised,
but for those reasons,
I'm out.
You are clinically insane
if you're giving these guys
reason to go on.
Lubetzky: I do not doubt that
you care about the environment,
about that stuff,
but your product
has to be your protagonist.
Your product
has to be your hero,
and it has to stand
on its own merits.
The social mission
can never be your crutch.
The social mission can never be
what you go to for a lifeline.
It's not a crutch.
It's our mission.
It's not.
It truly is our mission.
It's the reason we're committed
to doing this.
Seriously, it's the reason
we're committed to doing this.
We could've stayed, right?
We had done the math.
We could have been millionaires
in our early 30s.
Not just about the money.
That's not
what we wanted to do.
We wanted to make a difference
in the world,
and this is our way to do it.
Cuban: Good. Good.
Yeah, no one questions that.
Herjavec: But, Brian,
that doesn't make any sense.
‐Yeah, it does.
‐Why not?
‐Why?
‐It doesn't.
‐The reason ‐‐
It's not just because we want
to make a difference.
It's also because
we want to learn.
And we were at Google and Apple.
We had great jobs.
And we're thinking to ourselves
every night when we come home,
"We're not learning enough.
We're here at the office
and we're doing the tasks
that are being sent our way,
but we're not learning enough."
So it wasn't just about
making a difference.
It's about learning.
It's about building.
Brian, you be the nicest guy
in the world.
But your story has so many
lapses of credibility for me.
"Who's your competitor?"
"It's ice."
Like, come on, seriously?
We know there's a lot
of competition in
the cooler market.
We're not shying
away from that.
No, not at all.
This is the problem
we're trying to solve.
Then the story pivots
to sustainability,
and your product is made
of plastic, and ‐‐
Plastic that's meant
to last forever and
is fully recyclable.
Come on. I throw this in ‐‐
But if you use this product,
then you don't have to buy
the bag of ice.
And then you're like, "Well,
that's not really the story.
It's about learning something.
I wasn't learning enough
at Apple and Google."
Look, putting all that aside,
it was a bad presentation.
It was a bad presentation.
I'm out.
Appreciate that.
Thank you, Robert.
Greiner: I think it's gonna
be really important...
Thank you for your feedback,
Robert.
...for you to get
the cost down.
Yep.
People, when it's affordable
enough, they're gonna buy in.
And I think
that you have a shot.
What?!
Greiner: For me to invest,
it's not what I'm interested
in investing in.
So I'm sorry. I'm out.
Appreciate that.
Thank you for your feedback,
Lori.
Cuban: And then there's Daniel.
Lubetzky: I'm not 100% confident
this is a huge business.
But I'm very confident
that if you continue
pursuing your dreams,
you're gonna figure it out.
We will.
So I wish you the best.
I personally am out.
Cuban: Congrats on what
you've accomplished.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Alright.
Being on "Shark Tank,"
great experience,
but they
don't know everything.
We already have
retail partnerships in place.
We're gonna put our products
on shelves
so customers can see them
and love them.
And the Sharks are gonna wish
that they invested.
Why would you encourage them
to go on with this?
'Cause I think it's
a good‐looking product.
It really is
Oh, come on.
Greiner: So how long was your
anger management classes?
Listen, I really worked on it.
And look, I've been great.
I'm really ‐‐
I'm very ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a company
that believes two
is better than one.
♪♪
Together: Hi!
We are the Clark family!
I'm Manya.
I'm John.
I'm Juju.
I'm Lyla.
I'm Alleanna,
and this is Tandem Boogie.
We are from San Clemente,
California.
And we're seeking
$100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Our family has always loved
going to the beach together,
but we wanted to catch waves
on the same board.
So we created
the Tandem Boogie.
On the Tandem Boogie,
every wave is a party wave.
Take a look.
You can catch a wave
with anyone.
Whether you're a child
going into the ocean
for the very first time,
an adult that's been intimidated
by the waves,
or a teenager that just wants
to try something new,
the Tandem Boogie
is for you.
You can surf it.
You can ride it front and back
or side by side.
‐It takes two!
John:
Now, that's family fun.
Our patent‐pending
dynamic air design
allows us to make a board this
big fit into a bag that small.
You just show up at the beach,
you pump it up,
and then you've got a board
with handles and a camera mount
so you can capture
all of the action
and those memories
that will last forever.
So, Sharks, who wants to join
our Tandem Boogie family and...
Together: Help us bring the fun
to everyone.
Now, we want to ask Robert
if you'd like to come
and actually
try catching a wave.
‐Hi. Sure.
‐Alright.
Oh, you provide a pump,
as well?
Yes, we provide
the pump, as well.
So just grab onto
the handles.
You can
hold on to the ones ‐‐
Pretend like you're
catching a wave,
'cause there's waves
right behind you.
Whoo! Whoo! Whoo!
Ooh!
If I had my little one,
he would be here or she.
‐Yeah.
And then I would hang on.
‐Right.
‐Yeah.
You can do two people
side by side, too?
‐Yes, two people side by side.
‐Adults?
John:
Yep, we go side by side.
We're side by side
in the video, as well.
It's super fun.
Like, it feels very solid.
Wow. So you guys
are this great family.
I'm just curious, like,
who's running the business?
What's the story?
Well, we each
have our function.
I'm in charge of manufacturing,
operations,
logistics,
the website.
And I'm in charge of marketing
and sales and social media.
And I'm the CFO, which stands
for Chief Fun Officer.
I make sure that our brand
stays in line with our vision.
And I'm
the creative director.
I'm in charge
of the merchandising.
Alleanna: I'm in charge
of community outreach
and then also making sure
everybody gets the job done.
I'm the oldest sister.
I just love your unity.
Did you consciously
design something
that you could
involve your daughters in?
We had ‐‐ As a family growing up
in San Clemente, California,
we had participated in so many
different water activities.
There's actually a picture
of us,
all five of us
on one stand‐up paddleboard.
Herjavec: Oh, my gosh.
That is the cutest thing ever!
Greiner: Do you have
a background in this?
Yes. Well, John and I always
said that whatever he can sell
I can make.
I actually originally came here
to United States
from Iran as a refugee.
But by the time
I was 21,
I had my industrial
engineering degree
and was working in a big
corporation in manufacturing.
Wow.
So I know how
to make products.
Wow.
And John was always
a salesperson.
So we decided
when Juliette was 6 months ‐‐
we decided
to start a business,
and what we started
was a shelving business.
And it's been amazing
because our main object
for having the company
is to be able to spend time
with our kids.
And it's been a success.
We are still running it.
We do about $1,500,000
in sales per year.
‐Wow.
‐Good for you.
What do you
manufactured it for?
The landed cost
is $150.
O'Leary: $150?
And you sell it for how much?
Yes.
We sell it for $459.
‐Ooh.
‐Wow.
This idea of packaging it
into something portable
with the pump,
all‐in‐one‐fun kind of idea.
This is all you need.
Throw it in the back
of your scooter, your bike,
take it to the beach.
That's the selling proposition
to me,
because there are
other products like this.
Greiner: There are?
Don't be such a killjoy.
Herjavec: No, there are not.
Shut him down.
John: Well, what is unique
about our product,
We call it dynamic air design
because the design
is what we've perfected.
O'Leary:
But has anybody else done this?
Done this exact thing?
No.
John:
So we designed the board,
and then we consulted
with our attorney,
and we did file
for a patent,
a utility patent
on this design.
It has been submitted,
and that's for the whole design,
incorporating the handles,
the locations,
as well as the camera mount.
Cuban: Who goes out selling,
or is it only online?
How does the whole
sales process work?
Well, it's been a bit different
this year due to the pandemic.
So we had to pivot
towards selling online.
And what we actually
ended up doing
was we launched
a Kickstarter campaign
as our first, like,
way of selling.
So we did that
for one month,
and we've done $43,000
in sales.
Was that all on Kickstarter,
the $43,000?
$31,000 was from
the Kickstarter,
and that was between
June and July.
‐Of this year?
‐Yes.
‐Oh, you're brand‐new.
‐We're brand‐new.
‐Oh, you're brand‐new. Got it.
‐Oh, okay.
So the average boogie board
is 59, 69, 79 bucks,
depending on size,
under $100 for sure.
Are you getting a lot of
pushback on that price point?
Alleanna:
That's a great question.
What we found is that
this is comparable
to low‐cost surfboards,
and because you can have
two people on one board,
it's not like every person
needs their own.
Herjavec: Have you taken it
to the surf shops
and places
where people rent?
Have you tried that?
Part of the sales come
from the four retail stores
that we've already got
carrying our product.
What do you
need the money for,
and what do you
need a Shark for?
Well, our plan is,
we do feel that the opportunity
for Tandem Boogie is global,
and our plan is to grow.
We would like to have
25 accounts set up this year
so that we can reach
over $300,000 in sales.
We think that's realistic.
But how are you
gonna get there?
Your biggest challenge
will be distribution, that's it.
People will buy the product
if they see it.
Based on my experience
in sales and marketing,
I know how to set up dealers,
I know how to set up accounts.
I will contact them personally
like we did.
But, guys, you can't sell enough
just demo'ing the boards.
While you're gonna get
some retail distribution,
online will be where you
make your most money.
You know, you guys know
Tower Paddle Board.
What made it work
was the marketing ability,
the fact that Stephan
is just an expert at SEO, right?
That's what made it sell.
You've done this part.
But the part you don't have
is that SEO,
that sales skill, right?
It's not that you can't figure
out, but you're not there yet.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
So we're sorry that you're out.
We hope you reconsider.
Appreciate it.
Thanks.
Well, listen, I love the name.
I think it's fabulous.
It's intuitive.
You know just what it is.
But I feel like
with this product,
I think there's gonna be
better Sharks up here for you.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
O'Leary:
We've had water sports products
in here for over a decade,
and it's a tough grind
to get this to be a $5 million,
$10 million business.
And so I admire what
you've done, but I'm out.
Let me tell you
what I think.
Have you watched "Shark Tank"
for a while?
‐Oh, yes.
From Season 1.
We've all watched it
as a family.
Do you remember a family
that came out,
a dad with five sons
called Handboard?
‐Yes.
‐Yeah.
That was my investment.
They were
the California dream.
So it was a cross between
a paddleboard and a skateboard.
And I learned a lot
with Handboards.
But you have something
they didn't.
John: Right.
You have a patent.
I mean, for me,
that's really key.
But I need a bigger chunk
of the company.
'Cause it was a lot of work.
So I'll give you the $100,000,
but I want...
Well, I don't want 10%, John.
How much do I want?
Well, Robert, it is
a Tandem Boogie concept,
two people, right?
So are you interested
in just going this alone
as a solo Shark,
or would you like to have
a Tandem Boogie partner
from the panel?
Well, there's only
one other Shark left.
It's Daniel.
Daniel, what do you think?
Lubetzky: I'll tell you
my thoughts on this.
I love you guys.
This is a sport
that my family enjoys.
My wife loves this stuff.
My kids love this stuff.
I'm kind of the loser
in the family that's bad at it.
I have online expertise.
We sell over $100 million
online.
If Robert would like me to come
in on this to provide support,
I think we could do it for 25%
for the two of us.
25% isn't enough.
And I'm just being
completely sincere.
It is a lot of work,
and it's gonna take a long time.
$100,000 for 35%.
If Daniel wants to come in
as part of that, happy to do it.
I'd come in on that
if you guys ‐‐
Would you be willing to meet
in the middle at 30%?
No, no.
‐So mean!
‐You get Daniel ‐‐
You didn't come
into the Dolphin Tank.
We want to stay
on the Shark Tank.
Let's go sell some
Tandem Boogie boards.
‐Let's huddle up.
‐Can we huddle up, guys?
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Real quick?
[ Indistinct talking ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Robert...Daniel.
You can join
our Tandem Boogie family.
[ Cheering ]
Herjavec: Alright!
Daniel.
Congratulations, guys.
Well done.
Guys, congratulations.
‐Thank you.
‐See you guys.
[ Laughs ]
We got a deal, you guys!
Manya:
Well, Robert and Daniel are
a perfect fit for our family.
They're both immigrants.
They came to this country
as young kids, just like I did,
and made the American dream
come true.
And that's what
we're hoping for.
Herjavec:
What a fun family.
It's a fun business
in the front, what people see.
On the back, it's kind of like
the tech business.
Cuban: Hard. Hard.
It's hard.
Hard.
You guys are in
for a lot of work, baby.
It's our first deal together,
Daniel.
‐It's exciting.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
to make shopping easier
for parents.
♪♪
Fleischhauer:
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Lindsey Fleischhauer
from Naperville, Illinois.
And I'm Stan Valiulis
from Rockford, Illinois.
And we're the father/daughter
duo behind...
Both: Totes Babies!
Sharks, we're here
seeking $100,000
for 10% of our business.
How many parents have
dealt with this before?
The stress of shopping
with a baby?
The struggle is real,
right?
I mean, there's nowhere
to put the groceries.
You definitely don't want
to take the baby
out of the car seat.
What if they're sleeping?
What about germs?
Yuck!
And with a baby,
time is of the essence.
Groceries or baby?
There's only room for one.
Not anymore.
We have the solution ‐‐
the Totes Babies
Car Seat Carrier.
Shop with ease
and check off everything
on your shopping list.
It's time to make shopping with
babies fun, safe, and simple.
Now, for our
demonstration, Dad?
Simply lay the Totes Babies
over the shopping cart...
adjust the arm grips...
...put in the car seat.
Take it easy, Dad.
He's fragile.
Alright.
Adjust the safety straps.
‐And shop away.
‐Oh, wow.
Greiner: Oh.
Fleischhauer:
The Totes Babies works
on all different size
shopping carts
and holds up to 75 pounds.
What?!
It truly is shopping with babies
made fun, safe, and simple.
Alright, Sharks, who is totes
ready to jump in with us?
‐Very innovative, no question.
‐Yeah, very.
And that little scream
sounded a lot like Robert.
So I was impressed.
What?!
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Lindsey, did you
create this yourself?
And tell us how.
Well, the idea came about
with my first son.
You know,
being a new parent,
you just want to get out
of the house at some point.
And so I'd get all doodled up
to get out.
Then I'd have massive anxiety
when I couldn't get any
of my shopping list done.
And the light bulb
went off
when I was holding my big son
in his car seat,
holding the shopping basket,
and I couldn't get anything.
I was just like,
"I'm done."
I put the basket down.
And I kind of thought
of the idea and went to my dad.
I gave him
a very amateur drawing.
Not the best artist.
And he holds
over 40 patents.
‐So I went to him.
‐Oh, wow.
And he sketched up
an amazing drawing
and actually made a prototype
out of adjustable curtain rods,
electrical tape,
and a drop cloth.
‐And I used it at a store.
‐Way to go, Dad.
It worked great.
The moms were like,
"What is that?
Oh, my gosh," and I'm like,
"We're onto something."
I think once we saw it,
we thought we could really
make this into a real product.
I've worked with manufacturing
for most of my life,
really thought it'd be
the real deal.
Tell us, though.
Like, 40 patents?
It was a business
for store fixturing.
So we made products
for all the big‐box stores,
hardware stores.
I just can see stuff.
I know a lot
of manufacturing processes.
And for me,
it's a lot of fun.
When did you found this company,
and what are your sales today?
We launched in August
of 2018.
And what are your sales,
Lindsey, in that time?
$220,000.
Cuban:
And what does each one sell for?
$39.95.
And what does it
cost you to make?
$9.90, with tariffs
and freight included.
‐Wow.
‐How do you sell it?
Is it all online,
or do you go through ‐‐
We're on Amazon.
We're on buybuy BABY,
Bed Bath & Beyond,
and we sell through
our website, as well.
It's a phenomenal idea.
Thank you.
And I'm with you,
and I have twins.
I know.
How do you
get it out there?
Social media.
We have Facebook ads.
We have Instagram ads.
We have marketing through Amazon
that we work with.
How much have you spent
on advertising so far?
The total's got to be
about $20,000.
We just started boosting
our Facebook.
Oh, that's it?
Yeah.
We just started boosting it
the past couple months.
The way you were talking,
I figured ‐‐
No, we've been taking
baby steps, doing experiments.
Literally.
And now we're up to
2,500 bucks a month.
And the acquisition cost
is 15%.
So you guys
are a team together,
daughter, father ‐‐
really great.
Are you doing this
full time?
Yes, I am
doing it full time.
I'm actually so grateful
for Totes Babies.
And I won't get emotional,
but working with my dad
has been so awesome
because he's been my mentor
my whole life, and...
Guys! But it's been
an amazing experience
because I am a mom
but I love to work.
Being a mom is
one of the hardest jobs.
But having this business
gives me a purpose
and makes me
just feel awesome.
And I just knew, gosh,
if I ever thought of something,
who else would I want
to work with?
So it's been awesome.
Yeah, you can tell the respect
you have for him,
because when you just
look at him, you're beaming.
I've looked up to him
in so many different ways,
not only as a businessperson,
but as a dad.
I just hope to be
more like him someday.
She's a tremendous
daughter.
So, guys, have you gone
to grocery stores at all
and asked them
to try to sell this?
You know, if you saw these
standing up in a grocery store
and there's a stack
and it's $29.95...
Yeah.
Point‐of‐purchase display
right when you walk in.
Right when you walk in
and there's, like,
a big placard, right,
and it shows just
a picture like that,
then it's an obvious use
at a time of need.
But honestly, this is not
my type of business,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Mark.
Thank you.
O'Leary:
Listen, you guys are terrific,
but I don't think I can
add a lot of value here.
But very credible.
I applaud what you've done.
Thank you.
But I'm out.
Lindsey and Stanley,
I'm going to say
that your energy and your
charisma is really there,
and I think you're gonna
really figure this out.
I'm not sure that
I'm gonna be vital to you.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
I did have a KIND bar
the other day, though, so...
[ Laughter ]
Lindsey, I think you guys
have done a great job
of getting it out.
But I think the grocery business
is massive.
If you can capture
a percentage of that,
that would be a big,
big business.
Right.
I think I can really
help you with that.
Okay.
I'll make you an offer.
$100,000 for...25%.
I say let's blow it up
at the corporate level.
Let's go there.
That's what I do.
Okay.
So my thought is, I did
a deal with Baby Toon last year,
a little ‐‐ At 7 years old,
she created a baby spoon,
and it's like a teething ring.
Yep.
We licensed to Munchkin.
They're the number‐one
baby‐product people
in the world.
I think it would be great to do
some type of licensing to them.
So I will give you
the $100,000 for...
25% also.
Congratulations.
You got two offers.
‐What are you gonna do?
‐You got three offers.
I'll do it for 22%.
‐Whoa!
‐There you go.
The fun is building.
♪♪
Narrator: Two Sharks are out.
Lindsey and Stan have
three offers on the table
for their baby carrier holder
for shopping carts,
Totes Babies.
You got three offers.
I'll do it for 22%.
‐Whoa!
‐There you go.
The fun is building.
Lubetzky: 22%.
O'Leary: Three offers
in a tough category.
I think it's gonna be so much
fun working with you guys.
Valiulis: Yeah.
‐I'm back in.
‐Well, you know what, Lindsey?
Herjavec: I'd love to have him
part of it.
If he'll have me,
I'll go down to the 22%.
No, no, no, no, if we do it
together, it's at least 25%.
Okay, you're right.
Let's do it together.
So Daniel and I
will come in together.
We'll do it together,
Robert and I, for 25%.
Fleischhauer: $100,000 for 25%?
‐Yes.
‐That's awesome.
‐But you get two Sharks.
‐Lori?
And I am $100,000 for 25%.
And I think I like licensing
and selling and doing it all.
You can sometimes
get more Sharks
or you can sometimes
get more money
or less percentage, you know,
of equity stake,
but may not be
the best partner.
Oh, my God!
‐I feel I'm your best partner.
‐Wait a second.
"The other Sharks are bad.
I'm great."
I work with my entrepreneurs.
I hustle.
You can call me
anytime day or night.
Valiulis: Yeah, we know.
We hustle, too.
Lubetzky: I do want to make sure
you understand
that KIND is available
in more retailers ‐‐
I mean, we're in more
than 400,000 doors.
Everybody's amazing.
I'm just in shock
that we're here.
But you have to
make a decision.
‐Guys, every single grocery ‐‐
‐Can I say I love you all.
Loved your KIND bars.
Love you, Robert.
But, Lori.
Hold one second.
Do you understand that KIND
and I have the relationships
with every retailer
in the nation?
I will go down to 22%
if Daniel will go down to 22%.
They were about to say,
"Lori, you have a deal."
So, Lori, why are you
letting them out of it?
Lori, will you go down to 22%?
I'm gonna stick
because I think I'm worth it.
And I think that
you will be so happy
that you did a deal
with me.
I want to be in it
to win it with you.
You have a deal!
Whoo!
Yay!
Herjavec: Oh!
‐Yay!
‐Congratulations, you guys.
Lubetzky: You're gonna be
awesome, and best wishes.
This is a dream.
Thank you.
‐Yeah. You guys are great.
‐Thank you.
Whoo!
[ Squeals ]
I can't. I can't.
I can't, I can't, I can't.
Fleischhauer: My dad
has always been my mentor.
Now bringing Lori on
as another mentor
is just gonna skyrocket us
to the next level.
I just feel so proud of him.
I feel so proud of us.
We've come so far,
and it's amazing.
♪♪